yeah welcome to this video playing lot
Zhu from Norway I checked the Flex now
I'm not doing the guessing game again ok
let's see goof out o Kings Indian Kings
Indian let's play the five h3 line now
this is what I had to recommend it in
mind my older repertoire serious on one
default are the very cookie fire
interesting yeah what white I could
exchange now and get destroys castling
rides that's an online with the night
back on g8 and the porn on on h2 in this
case the exchange isn't so great i mean
can can play it but it's not not
fantastic maybe this i don't know i
could if i could have taken it's not not
bad probably but now we just ran
supposed to I rather regular type of
position he has a lot careful with their
there may be a ideas that you can can
try to her to make use of that
one a difference to them 5m to the to
the h3 line with the night is that a la
donna 3 is that you can play 92 year old
with g4 nagi three SS one idea
yeah sometimes you can even take with
the de pau on here in this in this
structure it's a quite interesting way
to play let's try that that's so it's
quite interesting it's that the idea is
that Queen to will win another temple on
what really okay yeah this is so just
just deliberately going into a
positionally almost lost position and
five is simply dead let's let's see how
to how to play this prom the f4 I'm
there for two to fix the spawn
so not for him to keep the podium on
there five even yeah just threatening to
take you five at f5 now it's also Queen
h5 so Queen h5 now or is this something
better yeah let's let's do this first
probably am queen to 27
so is always tied to the Sun weakness no
question is how to how to continue now
now let's keep it simple let's go to the
structure this is the easiest he's got
this big weakness on the B file and f5
threatening moves like rugby six now
rugby 62 f 6 picking up the pawn it also
route b5 now will be six
yeah just picking up once now f-5e from
this fault yeah I cannot sorry of him
sometimes to Frank here but Bishop f5 is
just cannot do this simply blundering
the game away you will lose a five you
have no minor piece to protect this pawn
and you will lose the pawn and then the
long run it's no way to avoid that it's
even a question if I am refuted this in
the most convincing way but I think it's
enough f-for make sure that the poor
never moves and here I'm always just
oops you can even know after this ok I
need to castle but he will never get rid
of this this weakness is a problem I
mean he would get rid of it if i take it
but he can has no way to to get any
dynamic play for this ok thanks for
watching